there's anger at the government on the
streets in Tehran pockets of protest
after Iran's military admitted it
accidentally shot down a civilian plane
they shout for their leaders to resign
amid the turmoil Britain's ambassador to
Iran was arrested Rob Mackerras held for
two hours before being released the
foreign secretary called his treatment a
flagrant violation of international law
he said the Iranian government is at a
crossroads moment it can continue its
path towards pariah status with all the
political and economic isolation that
entails or take steps to de-escalate
tensions and engage in a diplomatic path
for words the scenes of protests
contrasts with these images from last
week of nationwide grief Iranians
appeared to unite in horror after the
United States killed their most powerful
general the Revolutionary Guard avenged
his death by launching missiles at us
targets in Iraq but as they awaited
possible retaliation they accidentally
shot down Ukraine international airline
flight 752 this officer said the plane
was mistaken for an incoming cruise
missile hard to say well I confirmed
what had happened I really wished I
could die myself I said I wished I could
die it's not when there's such an event
for a lifetime we've made ourselves
ready to die for the people today we're
trading our reputation with Almighty God
it's an extraordinary admission of fault
about this tragedy after days of denial
slim comfort for the family and friends
of Iran's dead our children were killed
in the sky that's why we gathered
together here where do we go
president Trump wants more of them to
take to the streets
tweeting in English and Farsi he wrote
to the brave long-suffering people of
Iran I've stood with you since the
beginning of my presidency and my
administration will continue to stand
with you we're watching your protests
closely and are inspired by your courage
the world's also watching as Iran deals
with the fallout from the plane crash in
Canada which lost fifty seven of its
citizens there's anger shooting down a
civilian aircraft is horrific Iran must
take full responsibility these pictures
of the wreckage were released by
Ukrainian officials who have a team of
investigators on the ground you can
still make out what's left of the
cockpit blast marks documented as
evidence Iran believes the United States
shares the blame for stoking tensions in
the first place but it's forces fired
the fatal shot Tehran will now have to
live with the consequences